so I why are there so few stories about
women in mainstream films in your
opinion because women are the ultimate
powerful people and men want to keep
them down I don't know I think maybe it
has to do with I think in the world
women are I mean it's can we start that
ever I think the world is changing a lot
and I think women are becoming gaining
more and more power in the world and I
think even from the 50s he's been from
you know 50 years ago I mean it's a
completely different world we as women
we work we run the home we're like you
know i can bring home the break and fry
it up in a pan you know and never let
you forget your mouth but but no really
i mean it's a women are very powerful
we're doing things we're putting
ourselves in power positions you can you
can go have a baby by yourself if you
want to men I mean it's a very different
world and maybe we're just trying to
figure out what that world is and get
out of the man powered base and make it
more equal but you know I think people
are kind of discovering what their roles
in life are right now and I think there
are more and more movies about women I
think there's more of a consciousness
that there aren't a lot of movies about
that or that the women are put in these
kind of side roles and I think people
are getting mad about it because that's
not really how the world is now women
aren't getting put in these side roles
as much we are equals or becoming equals
and and it seems unfair so I think the
world let you know I think it happens
all the time we recalibrate and we
figure it out and then you know maybe
it's a hard time to make independent
films or whatever but they'll be you
know a group of them they go for it and
get out there and it'll be these
transformative films that make it so
that there's a new way of being able to
make films and a new way to talk about
stuff and you know just a constant
evolution so I think the more we can
support that I'm sure in 20 years from
now this will be an obsolete come
asian yeah so what have been the typical
films about women if they're the main
stars in the film I mean you know it's
right into the 90s and to now that
there's really not that women centric
foam I mean you had all these Shirley
MacLaine's and Meryl Streep and
everybody in these a man bank often
general ins and you have these amazing
women doing amazing parts all the time
and maybe they were half the man and
thing but they weren't ever the you know
even you know you think like it's not
even his girl Friday or something it's
like even though that's a really
powerful role from the 20s to 30s or 40s
50s got a little weird 60s were back 70s
80s 9 and then in the 90s it just turned
into something else and so I think we
just have to get back get out of that
you know and rhythm and get back into a
new rhythm so you'd like to see female
characters that are a whole person not
just a quirky you know Thelma and Louise
let's go on this sort of you know even
though wonderful fun I tried no no it
just yes I would I like to see all
characters more well-rounded not just
women all characters i would like to see
you know what makes someone tick in a
movie why what the motivation is and you
know i think we need to everybody needs
to pay a little bit more attention to
the scripts
you